[Music]
making a polished animation takes
hundreds of people millions of dollars
in huge Studios but what if I told you
the clips you're watching right now were
created with free software and just a
couple of buddies working together
[Music]
and you might be saying Nico those are
just a couple Clips there's no way you
guys can do a whole episode of a cartoon
you aren't even traditional animators
well watch as we attempt to invent a new
way of doing animation and if we pull it
off you will see stories from small
creators like us we've never seen before
[Music]
thank you
all right so we are currently filming
anime rocket processors too like filming
an enemy aren't you supposed to be
drawing an anime also you're probably
wondering yourself why I'm dressed up
like a little kid let me give you a
quick background here so over the past
year there's been an explosion machine
learning for image generation and it's
been kind of a Grassroots community-led
thing rather than like a corporate
development we took a bunch of that and
experimented with it which culminated in
a project that we made called animate
rock paper scissors
foreign
film parody of anime but what was unique
is that we used one of these machine
learning image models called stable
diffusion to convert real footage of
ourselves on a green screen into
cartoonified versions of ourselves and
people really respond to this story and
we were decently successful in
translating that anime style the thing
is we've always wanted to make a full
episode of an anime not just a YouTube
short but a whole episode with a full
story and all that kind of stuff and we
want to make that happen with anime rock
paper scissors too I'm super excited we
already did the hard part which is like
the real acting of the voice acting so
this is literally just us being puppets
all day and playing around the first
rock paper scissors while it was
visually cool there's also a lot of
technical shortcomings the faces get
really wonky at Parts the style gets
screwed up parts and it kind of looked
more like a video filter than an actual
proper cartoon and this time we wanted
to push beyond that this time we need to
transform these characters so to test if
that's possible we are shooting the
first scene of anime rock paper scissors
too where we are looking at the princes
when they are young children that means
well either we film with kids or we use
the promise in this new technology and
we film ourselves and we turn ourselves
into those characters as kids they say
uh never film with animals or children
so we're using machine learning to
eliminate jobs from children I know I
know people might get upset you know
limiting those jobs for kids you know
getting rid of that child employment but
then you gotta do what you gotta do what
we're filming on the green screen me in
this costume it's not just gonna be the
same thing but filtered I need to
transform my my jawline needs to change
this wig needs to look like real hair I
need to transform into a character not
just be redrawn with lines around my
face we don't really know if any of this
is going to really work this is all
theoretical right now we actually
haven't done it this is effectively our
test if it works then the whole project
is a green light and we're going to
attempt to make a full episode of our
very own anime I don't know that this is
going to work with Nico with the beard
we didn't we didn't do any tests on a
bearded man as a boy my fear is that
we're going to have a lot of weird AI
artifacts on Nico's character from the
beard and if we can't make that work
then this day of shooting is kind of
ruined and the video itself might not
work
so uh we'll see how that works out
Nico this beard this beard issue issue
so you're worried about like having a
baby face have you seen the Adventure
Time video that we did on Corridor I
have not shaved since this video since
11 years ago look no no if it didn't
work this beard was gonna go I'm more
interested in making a good video than
keeping my beard but I'm also interested
in using the world's most advanced
computer science to not have to shave
all right so I'm going to start by
showing you some still images converted
using everything we've learned since the
first video
[Music]
that is so stylistically different than
like the first anime rocket processors
like this looks like a cartoon but Nico
so we take those settings and run a
video of you through and apply some
light compositing this is what we get
look at that it worked and look you're
ma like you can read the mouth movements
it's like a little it's a little wobbly
in the sense like it's a real motion of
a person it's working and there's still
some work left to do here but this is
super promising like this is such a this
is like a full body deep fake you know
Nico it would have been easy to shave
your beard but in not wanting to have a
baby face you actually pushed us into a
new frontier of Technology here hey what
can I say I'm a great leader you know
oh it worked my beard is gone this means
we can green light the project it means
we can go and move forward and make rock
paper scissors too which is actually
pretty daunting considering how huge
this project is by our count the second
rock paper scissors will have 400 shots
the first one had 80. the second rock
paper scissors have seven characters the
first one had two second rock paper
scissors has a whole bunch of
environment changes the first one only
had one so there's a lot of things we
have to figure out
so if you look at rock paper scissors
one that was us experimenting it was us
basically doing kind of like a fan film
parody of anime specifically like 90s
anime and also testing this technology
to see if it would work and when we made
anime rock paper scissors one we used
frames from the movie Vampire Hunter D
bloodlust to kind of create our style a
lot of people have eaten criticisms at
us for using the vampire 100d images now
if you look specifically at the style of
rock paper scissors one if you look at
the frames they don't actually look 100
like vampire 100d bloodlust there's
certainly like some DNA in there but one
of the problems with rock paper scissors
one is that it's just kind of a generic
look it doesn't have its own style and
it changes throughout the faces get
drawn and interpreted a little bit
differently if we're going to make our
own episode of a cartoon that is our own
thing we need to fix that you need to be
able to see the characters clearly as a
style that only exists in the rock paper
scissors universe and it needs to be
consistent so when you see the character
in different scenes from different
angles it still feels like it's the same
character drawn by the same artist so
with real cartoons they actually have a
way to fix this there's something called
a model sheet and basically they outline
how the character should be drawn from
different angles what the proportions
are and this is given out to artists so
they all can draw the character in a
consistent way in theory if we do
something similar for rock paper
scissors too we should also be able to
define a look for our characters that
can then consistently be applied to them
and for this I have a long time artist
friend I'm going to reach out to and
he's going to help us design the look
for rock paper scissors too to create
these character model sheets and if
successful we should be able to Define
our own style for this episode hi Josh
it's me your longtime buddy Nico
what were some of the key aspects to the
style that you tried to develop but what
would you say at your signature traits
the things that I tended to exaggerate
were cheekbones chins you got angular
feature that looked like a great cheese
on them
um and obviously exaggerated eyes
probably the most prominent of all brows
everything was a rushed downward I'm not
traditionally an anime artist so
studying everything from the Empire
Hunter D to dundum like getting to push
those characteristics those
personalities to an extreme that's so
satisfying to do
wow I'm just realizing I think it's
still clear sketchbooks
as an artist you have a computer that is
looking at your drawings and learning
how to apply them to video and how does
it feel being on that spectrum of
Technology the AI that we were we've
been exploring is beautiful and exciting
while also being a little unnerving and
I feel like that's okay
you guys were kind enough to solicit me
and actually compensate me but for all
the thousands of artists out there it's
that
are also getting sucked up by that jet
engine of the AI but not being solicited
or compensated or even told that it's
happening my heart goes out to them the
things that people are worried about
like sound animation can be so easy to
create we don't need animators anymore
that's true if you want to tell the most
generic diluted story that's already
been told a thousand times if ever you
wanted to be like original tell a unique
story you need to feed it more original
art and you need to just flood it
because it needs to learn something new
to tell a new story and if you don't do
that it just starts to become kind of a
generic amalgamation of all animations
the best possible thing for it is that
creatives descend on it ones that
actually have moral compasses and
passions and things they care about
because this generation can provide the
template that future Generations use
when asking themselves like what's the
right way to handle this hey all of you
go check out level one art major on
Instagram see some of Josh's work thanks
for taking the time Josh I'll talk to
you soon thank you have a good one
so Nico you tell me that your friend
Josh has made us some dope art yeah we
have a bunch of cool pictures also some
pictures of your character I have him
right here actually yeah he's basically
the handsome Squidward version of me yep
I feel like eyes are the most critical
thing that's the thing we have to kind
of get right especially after the last
one the eyes would be constantly
changing colors yeah so we have our
photo set our data set that we did for
you so I took these photos as well as
the art from Josh and I trained up a
model and tried running it on these
photos to turn these photos into
basically the Josh's version of you
oh whoa It's like his style but shrink
wrapped to my proportion right the the
way the lips are drawn is exactly the
same like like the corners of the mouth
like it's doing a little bit of a line
for the philtrum but at the same time it
also has the shading there the cleft
chins coming through it's also worth
noting that like it's taking his style
and like bringing the costume to life
through his style also like it's looking
at how he's handling color and contrast
and shape I mean you've got like the job
Henry Cavill and all these yeah the
drawings did I'll take it
so this looks like it's pretty much
ready to like run an entire video
through it
yeah
um
I tried I tried doing that I'm not gonna
say anything just tell me what you think
okay
I mean it's like it's kind of coming
through I think because there's so much
flicker once you smooth it out it just
kind of goes back to being that like
neutral cartoon style you know it's
pretty rough it's like if I pause it
like this the frame's not that bad it's
kind of getting Josh's eye shape it is
getting the cleft chin but man when I
hit play it is just like it is all over
the place every frame is different the
eyes are moving around it's it's like
about where we were at like the last
week of the first one and it was the
best looking stuff we got for the
original piece I don't know it doesn't
feel like that big of a leap yeah it
doesn't look like it doesn't
but I don't want this to be just as good
as the first one I want to be good I
want to be really good it's a sequel
it's got to be it's got to be a leap so
Nico I feel like you've lost a bit of
Hope but I sense there's still hope
within you because if this wasn't
working I mean we've spent a ton of time
on this I feel like you'd be way more
upset I don't know what we're going to
do but there there's this thing called
warp fusion which is created by this guy
named Alex it was actually out when we
were doing the first rock paper scissors
and I tried to use it but it didn't have
our reconstructed noise thing that we
were using so our stuff would be warbly
I had tried using it for our stuff I
think our method was better but I just
saw this animation posted like yesterday
by this this guy named enigmatic e he
has a YouTube channel and it's very
similar to what we're doing here take a
look at this oh whoa yeah the face reads
the pose reads like the lines and the
detail like there's a little bit of
shift in Shimmer but like this is really
cool like if there's an animation like
this like this would be sick the details
carry through even though it's such a
huge departure from the original Dude it
takes those details and carries them
forward is that kind of what warp fusion
is doing yeah like warp fusion it takes
your image and it creates an optical
flow pass basically tracks where things
move and it morphs the previous frame
using that Optical flow to where the the
things would be in the current frame so
it kind of pulls data from the last
frame and warps it the current frame and
then fills in like the gaps and things
that need to be fixed but you get a lot
of the data from the previous frame so
rather than every frame being a new
frame you're actually kind of cheating
the system and getting it to look back
and keep some temporal consistency going
so kind of at a point where like our
only option if we want to make this
project is to try something new so I
think I need to download warp fusion and
learn how to use it damn dude that would
be going back to the drawing board yeah
essentially like we would have to we
would have to redo everything we've done
already we're like two months into this
project almost and like we would have to
throw out everything we've done we'd
have to change our whole pipeline but if
we have any hope of actually saving the
project and making this work I mean from
what I'm seeing warp fusion looks like
it might work I mean from that animation
alone it's worth a shot
just it's so much python code and
githubs I'm just I don't want to have to
do it again I think you have to lock
yourself in this room and you go
you have to lock yourself in this room
not leave until you have like usable
results
I'll do whatever it takes
[Music]
so Nico you seem very excited to show
this to us so you know my buddy Josh
he's been doing a whole like art style
for this and we took that art style and
we did some initial tests you look at it
it's like yeah it's not awful but it's
like on par with rock paper scissors it
feels similar to yeah over this past
weekend I started experimenting with
warp fusion I actually spoke to Alex and
asked him to implement reverse noise or
reconstructed noise no one knows what to
call it basically when you derive the
noise from the image and he did so I
decided to jump back in and I'll show
you the results
all right
wow wow yeah that's amazing because
that's a really tricky shot that's like
a it's a big difference
look how look how nice this one is
[Music]
wow
wow this looks a thousand times better
than everything else you've showed us
it's my this is my halo moment when he
first played Halo you know you're like
this is it it can't get better like this
looks so good anyway so I'm having that
moment right here done all right we're
done we're done that's the end so you
figured it out and now we can do
cartoons for real without any Jank
is that are we ever gonna get to that
point well the only thing that stops
changing is us when we decide to stand
still
I still can't get over the fact that
like brand new visual effects technique
is in our hands as open source free
software it's crazy we're running this
on our our PCS if you have a decent
gaming PC you can do this yourself the
thing is I had to experiment and figure
out my way through this and a bunch of
people helps me on Discord and various
communities it's amazing I figured I
could help out a little bit just make a
tutorial for anybody out there who wants
to do what we're doing if you want to
try doing this I have made a full
tutorial series that's going on our
website quarterdigital.com we cover
everything from fine tuning model to
using more fusion compositing and we
also have a community challenge at the
End plus a whole Discord server it's
gonna be a good time if you want to
learn how to do this Corridor
digital.com there's a free trial you can
check it out all right so we still have
hundreds of shots to figure out so let's
get back to it
she used to yeah that's a lot of red
yeah I mean look more Fusion works it's
a generational leap from what we were
doing with rock paper scissors one
however this means starting over on all
of our shots all this red is stuff that
we have to do it's it's a shot that
needs to be run through orb Fusion it
needs to be composited some shots have
multiple characters so you're running
multiple characters through orb Fusion
it's a lot of work imagine each one of
these being like three to four hours
dude this deserves an anime reaction
seems like a hell of a lot of work it is
a hell of a lot of work and there's no
two ways about it but Nico why can't I
just type in anime movie and then it
comes out why do we got to do all this
look you can type in anime movie and
something comes out but no one cares
what comes out when you type an anime
movie people only care when you give it
Direction an artistic intent and
creativity we'll do it on there let's
get it done so here's my solution I'm
going to attempt to build build a online
team of warp fusion artists I was on the
warp fusion Discord a bunch of people
were helping me out a bunch of people
are making cool art a bunch of people
are fans of corridor if we break out
these shots maybe we can have like a
group of bounty hunters grab two or
three shots run them they can get paid
for those shots I could reach out to
kaitra she's been super helpful I can
reach out to uh enigmatic e Eric you
know the guy that basically taught me
how to install warp fusion with his
tutorials meanwhile we will in parallel
make a compositing team here in the
studio we know how to do that kind of
stuff we have a couple cool animators we
could hire kenson for example helped us
out in the first rock paper scissors
you're probably gonna need somebody to
also help manage the edit maybe Matthias
wants to come back in and help us out
with that this one we just solved by
talking to people and trying to find
people who are talented at doing this
stuff to help us out wait Nico are you
saying you're going to hire artists
ironic isn't it
new technology doesn't make me want to
slow down it doesn't make me go like oh
I guess I don't need help anymore it
makes me want to speed up it's like oh I
can do even more now so let's do more
yeah we can make bigger and better stuff
now let's do it
so we're all slowly making our way
through the spreadsheet this is where
the fun begins because we all get to be
purely artists we get to take these
plates and sort of break them apart and
put them back together again combined
with the backgrounds which Sam captures
an Unreal Engine then converts into the
anime style with stable diffusion and
then we add 2D hand-drawn elements and
even 3D Elements which we add in the
composition to add that kind of final
layer of sauce this creative process is
accelerated greatly by our beastly
workstation PCS provided by our friends
over at Puget systems this is a
subjective medium we filmed a plate of
someone we put a filter on it and that's
cool but the Artistry in making these
shots sell whether they're like big
impacts or big moments that comes from
the creativity of constructing a dynamic
shot after the fact you know we're just
working with two plates here but like
what else can you to it that really
brings it to life like it's really fun
being incredibly bombastic and over the
top with these shots I think that's
where the fun comes from for me anyways
it's it's so funny sometimes thinking
about how ridiculous the concept is
these twins that play Rock Paper
Scissors but I think it's also proof of
how effective these techniques are
despite the actual like plot of it this
method allows us to get the most
over-the-top intensity which helps you
actually get invested in a Preposterous
story and speaking of over-the-top
intensity this wouldn't be an episode of
anime without an anime theme song
luckily we have a talented musician to
provide the title track
so my name is David Maxim mitich and I'm
a composer and a producer from Belgrade
Serbia how is it trying to write an
anime theme song this was very very fun
for me like there's so many animals that
just like draw you in with their title
track having a reference that you guys
provided it was easy I would just like
follow the concept that you guys already
have when listening to it it still has
your signature sound nice like I don't
know there's something just about your
your writing then we take the vocals and
then have the vocalist who goes by the
name shihori translate the lyrics as
well she did a really good job too
she did an awesome job
you did the the rest of the music
yourself right I did uh I got this
incredible old synth module from like
1999 and it had so many of those like
crazy early 90s synthesizer patches on
it but it even has like the dues for
Metal Gear Solid really
that was like my big excitement with
doing some of the music here putting in
some of those like cheesy sounds to make
it feel like a 90s anime
once again dude I just I gotta thank you
because the music is incredible it's a
hit nice where do we go so hear more of
your stuff Spotify my website all the
regular places I do well have a great
one bye bye
all right it's midnight
big moment all right you see that last
little red thing there each red clip
means there's notes and the last shot
with notes has been dealt with this is
it
the last one
oh where we did it is that all the shots
every single shot in the piece is
shippable we could upload this now and I
would probably be okay with it and I
think everybody would enjoy it a
Project's never done until you give up
but at least at this point we could
upload it so everything from here on
that is just us indulging in ourselves a
little bit so we do have the final bonus
scene at the very end I was thinking of
a skit Dean tell me what you think so
every Soldier is played by Jordan Allen
in this piece they're all like clones of
each other Jordan Allen is a soldier and
Jordan Allen is a peasant walks by and
the jail and Soldier says
he looks up he's like there's gonna be a
big battle in episode three but only if
we get enough troops he's like well how
do I help and he's like you can sign up
at quarterdigital.com it's like okay and
it just cuts the two of them in guard
uniforms like hey this is pretty nice
and that's the end of the piece hi
so I don't know that's our little like
what push to the website if you want to
see an episode three that's how you do
it also we have a full three-part
tutorial that covers in detail every
single step of this process so you can
learn how to make cartoons using your
camera and a green screen on your
computer yourself it's surprisingly
accessible like who would have thought
Cutting Edge Tech like this would be in
our hands for us to be able to play with
there is something beautiful about
something that would take the
traditional Studio hundreds of people
and years could now be done by five
friends with a little time on their
hands who may not have the tactical
chops like the knowledge of construction
method and rendering but they have a
really satisfying story to tell and they
want it to be heard that's gorgeous
[Applause]
[Music]